one month to go before the summer movie
season starts time to flood the theater
with the forgettable z' date night so
right off the bat I'll admit that I'm
probably not the demographic that date
night aims for it seems to be made for
the midlife crisis married couples of
the world or young married couples of
the world a miserable miserable so Steve
Carell and Tina Fey play a married
couple who feel like their lives kind of
becoming routine and mundane so on this
particular date night they make it
really special if I go into a really
expensive restaurant that happens to be
totally booked and so they do what
anyone would do they take someone else's
reservation
I mean who hasn't done that I mean yeah
I've never done that and so it becomes a
case of mistaken identity when a couple
of mobster thugs played by common and
liam mcpoyle think that they're the ones
who ripped off their boss you know
because they took the other couples
reservation so now they think they're
then always funny and so the Chasen
shenanigans ensue now I thought Steve
Carell and Tina Fey played a really good
couple in this movie they both have
really good chemistry together and they
both have really good comedic timing but
the premise of this movie is just really
tired I mean from the get-go you feel
like you've seen this movie a hundred
times before and you know exactly how
it's gonna play out I mean granted the
movie had a couple of laughs and it even
had a car chase scene that's not
entirely plausible but I still thought
it was really cool or these kind of cool
but to be honest a couple of laughs just
are not enough the important thing is
that the audience connects with the
movie and in that there are a few things
in life that I am just not 40-something
married and bored with my life happened
to be three of them and so as I
mentioned before that seems to be the
demographic that this movie reaches out
to but even then I can't see how a movie
that's so routine a big mistaken
identity adventure that feels flat and
predictable complete with the premise
that this adventure is exactly what they
need to rekindle that spark in their
marriage as they're pursued by really
dumb criminals is worth paying for
anyone I mean I'm not totally detached I
enjoyed adventures and babysitting as
much as the next guy wait our guys
supposed to enjoy that movie but I'm not
above liking a good romantic comedy
hitch so I married an axe murderer
wedding singer American Psycho but
unlike those movies by the end date
night doesn't become more than just
forgettable I mean it's like I always
say the Internet is huge you can find an
abundance of free laughs anywhere
Hollywood cannot rely on just a couple
of laughs to support an entire movie
when tickets cost 10 bucks age so I'm
starting to sound like a really jaded
vexed prick of a broken record but I
gotta say skip this movie too
but I am curious if you're married and
your wife happens to drag you along to
this movie let me know what you think of
it I'd like to hear the input of someone
who might be more the demographic that
this movie is trying to reach out to
maybe I'm just wondering if I am a jaded
prick so let me know oh and one more
thing I've gotten a lot of requests from
people asking me to review kick-ass guys
I will definitely review kick-ass I just
reviewed date night if we live in a
world where I review date night and not
kick ass you yes you right there you you
can punch me in the neck cross my heart
and all that
I can't wait for gay guys and until next
time I'm now gonna punch you in the face
[Music]